[Applause]
[Music]
so my friends for some time now here on
visualpolitik we've been telling you
about how africa has begun to pivot to
change its position
on the roulette wheel of economic
fortune we have spoken at length for
example about the cases of rwanda and
ethiopia
two countries that until just a few
years ago were amongst the poorest on
the african continent but now
against all odds have begun to take off
however in spite of this i am sure that
when i ask the following question
the answer will be practically the same
what is the first thing that comes to
mind when you think
of sub-saharan africa i'm sure it goes
without saying that for a lot of you the
answer will be the same as always
poverty hardship and tragedy however as
we have already told you on several
occasions
in many cases this stereotype is
beginning to change of course as we
often say the evidence tells us that the
future is not set in stone
nor is africa a single country in other
words we'll be able to find very
different realities
and trends on the continent
for example the situations of kenya and
tanzania are vastly different despite
the two countries sharing a border
having achieved independence almost
simultaneously
and the fact that both economies had a
similar level of income
at the time they achieved independence
today however in terms of purchasing
power
parity i.e taking into account the
differences in prices
kenyans are 80 percent richer than their
neighbors
after independence both countries became
dictatorships but while kenya managed to
move towards a more democratic
market-oriented model tanzania was
subjected for decades to a socialist
dictatorship that nationalized large
companies and forced people to work on
collective farms
[Music]
it's a similar situation when you talk
about zimbabwe and botswana even though
these countries also share a border and
even though
back in 1980 zimbabwe was by far the
richer of the two nations
all of which is a very very different
situation to the current one
because today botswana a country that
opted for stability and a free market
economy
is not only seven times richer than
zimbabwe but
in per capita terms whichever way you
look at it it has a higher income level
than countries like colombia
brazil and ecuador
so you see the truth is that if we put
on our explorer's uniform we'll be able
to find
very different realities within
sub-saharan africa differences that will
only become more and more pronounced
this is the phenomenon of what is
already known as the african lions
countries that after decades of massive
corruption violence
and the systemic enrichment of
oligarchic elites or the influence of
african socialism a political ideology
nurtured supported and promoted by the
soviet union and cuba during the second
half of the 20th century
are now beginning to take off because
there is a way out of poverty but be
careful
it's not such a straightforward path so
my visualpolitik friends
this time we're going to take a look at
a very different story from the one we
all imagine
when we think of sub-saharan africa are
you ready to embark with us on this new
journey into the unknown if so
welcome to mauritius let's get cracking
[Music]
the most prosperous island in africa
is an island republic made up of four
main islands and located in the indian
ocean about a thousand kilometers that's
just over 600 miles away from madagascar
a trip from this place to europe or
north america will usually require
several flights we are talking about a
very very small country
barely two thousand kilometers squared
formerly a french colony and then later
a british one
which in spite of everything has been
the only african country to reach the
top rankings of the human development
index prepared annually by the united
nations it's a country that was
completely dependent on sugar cane crops
in the 1960s but is now home to one of
the most important financial and tourist
hubs in africa
that and the price adjusted gdp per
capita that the world bank estimates at
about 24 000
almost as much as chile and six times
higher than the average for sub-saharan
africa now at this point many of you are
probably wondering alright alright grunt
but
how have they done this how on earth
does a small remote island country
located
far from anywhere else in the world
escape from extreme poverty and go from
growing sugarcane to survive to becoming
a financial and
tourist hub well the key my friends lies
in a series of political
economic legal and social reforms that
made the country one of the most legally
secure in
all of africa if not the most so
[Music]
but to find out how and when this whole
story was set in motion we have to go
back to the 1970s during that decade
mauritius suffered a severe economic
crisis
a crisis that had been brewing since
years earlier due to the lack of
diversification of its poor agrarian
economy
high unemployment a population that was
growing too fast
and a small political and social elite
that controlled most of the wealth and
that wasn't exactly down to natural
economic processes
of course faced with such a scenario and
taking into account its location the
country was isolated from international
markets and its capacity to obtain
foreign financing or investment was
practically
non-existent in order to escape from
this pit mauritius needed to implement
deep political and economic reforms
and surprisingly considering the african
reality of the time
that's exactly what they did they put in
place a huge package of reforms that we
can divide into three phases
[Music]
the first in the 1970s and taking
advantage of sugar revenues involved the
creation of an export processing zone
something like a special economic zone
this was a protected area in which the
government implemented a series of tax
and regulatory benefits in order to
boost industrial production and exports
and do you know what as in many other
places where we talk about here the
experiment
this first approach to the global free
market was also a success
in a short time manufacturing companies
from nine different sectors
set up shop ninety percent of the
companies were local and so
based on these results the mauritian
authorities realized that creating an
economy oriented to the rest of the
world could be very
very lucrative so how could they
compensate for their remote geographical
location it didn't take long to see the
obvious
in the second phase of reforms between
the 1880s and 1990s this export
processing zone was expanded and its
advantages
broadened as a result foreign investment
soared and a new sector began to
flourish from the ground up
tourism a sector that has been
fundamental to the development of
mauritius and today
accounts for nearly 20 of the country's
gdp it's no coincidence that the main
island is known
as beach island but the reforms did not
end there
in the second phase capital movements
were also deregulated a low tax model
was implemented many of the existing
regulations were eliminated and even
banking secrecy was established for a
time what happened in mauritius
stayed in mauritius something that by
the way meant the country was to be for
years right up until 2019
listed on national and international
lists of tax havens or non-cooperative
jurisdictions
[Music]
but my friends the point is that in this
way mauritius developed a very financial
and free market-oriented
economic culture for example the tax on
profits comes to 15 percent a percentage
that is reduced to between zero and
three percent for offshore companies
that is to say
companies whose tax headquarters are
located in mauritius but whose
activities are concentrated outside
of the country in mauritius by the way
there is also no capital gains tax that
is you don't pay tax on dividends or
interest received
such an economic architecture which was
further improved and consolidated during
the third phase between 1990 and 2010
led to an increase in investment in the
country and the development of an
international financial industry their
policies attracted banks
investment fund managers insurance
companies and even a lucrative business
of incorporated companies
looking to improve their tax structure
and friends to give you an idea of what
we are talking about according to
estimates by the country's financial
services commission there are more than
21 000 international corporations
registered in mauritius whose combined
assets spread around the world
exceed 600 billion dollars more than
40 times the national gdp
in mauritius this is what is mostly
known as gbc
global business companies these are
companies that are resident and
mauritius and therefore
tax liable and mauritius but whose
shares are nevertheless majority
controlled by persons or companies
not resident and mauritius and which are
engaged in businesses
mainly abroad
but that's not the end of it in fact
over the last two decades the number of
millionaires
living in mauritius has grown faster
than in any other african country which
naturally has also been real fuel for
its financial fund management industry
according to afro-asia bank data the
number of foreigners residing in
mauritius with a net worth of more than
one million dollars has
tripled over the last decade there are
now almost 4 000 millionaires mainly
from france and south africa and hey
with the beaches
security and low taxes well what's not
to like but
wait a minute let's put on the brakes
for just one second because i know what
you're thinking grant this is a tax
haven right you're really you're talking
about a tax haven well my friends
it is clear that it is controversial
even if we are talking about the only
country in sub-saharan africa that has
achieved a very high level of human
development and so
there are some questions we have to ask
ourselves at this point so let's see
was mauritius becoming a kind of tax
haven a good or bad thing for the rest
of the african continent how did it
manage to gain the trust of so many
international investors what did
mauritius have for the countries like
liberia belize or vanatu which have also
been considered non-cooperative
countries in tax matters
not have well let's start with the first
question
[Music]
many of you may be tempted to think that
the existence of places like mauritius
has been a bad thing for the rest of
sub-saharan africa however
nothing could be further from the truth
before you start shouting at the screen
let me explain a whopping sixty percent
of the investments of international
companies registered in mauritius which
are channeled from
russia's are destined for the countries
of continental africa
mains hotels factories real estate
developments and so on and so forth we
are therefore talking about investments
that obviously generate jobs
production and economic activity of all
kinds in african countries
not only in mauritius activities but
thanks to which by the way
the african states where the activities
are located also receive taxes such as
for example
taxes on labor consumption or real
estate itself in other words they
receive tax on the wealth
generated by these investments but then
the question is why register or channel
these investments from mauritius well my
friends it's not only a question of
taxation there's another even more
important element something that is
precisely what differentiates this
country's from other tax havens such as
liberia
or belize
the fact is that mauritius has one of
the most secure legal and political
systems in all of africa a system that
provides a great deal of legal certainty
to its citizens and also to foreign
investors
as a result this country has a judicial
system considered by international
organizations to be quite efficient and
independent free and mostly fair
elections a relatively high level of
freedom of expression
and a balanced power structure where the
president the prime minister
and the national assembly share
functions and power thus
acting as counterweights
and that's not all according to the
world bank mauritius has become one of
the 13 countries in the world where is
easiest to do business
and according to the heritage
foundation's index of economic freedom
it is one of the 25s freest economies in
the world and number one
in africa well it is precisely all these
characteristics that make a relatively
safe and stable country and that is why
foreigners choose to register
deposit and channel their investments
destined from sub-saharan africa
from here as we've told you many times
before no matter how low your taxes are
without legal certainty and political
stability there will be of no use to you
obviously
this makes sense no one is going to take
their money no matter how low the taxes
are to a place
where they can be robbed in broad
daylight at this point however many of
you may be wondering whether mauritius's
economic progress has not only favored
businesses but also the mauritians
themselves
i mean we all know how these things go
it's not unusual especially the
considering that we're talking about
africa that in the end the good news
remains good news for only a select few
well the short answer is that this
doesn't seem to be the case for this
island republic but
do you want some hard facts if so check
this out
[Music]
poverty in the country was reduced to
12.7 in 2019
and extreme property is practically
eradicated from the country less than
one percent are in that group
all of this has been achieved thanks to
an average annual economic growth of 4.6
between 1977 and 2008. this growth has
also allowed the country to reduce its
genie coefficient
of equality to levels close to those of
countries such as spain australia or the
united kingdom this tells us that all
this economic growth has favored
all segments of the population
with all this data in hand it seems
clear that we are facing a new african
lion which perhaps
you have hardly never heard of now does
all this mean that a place like
mauritius is on its way to securing its
place among the ranking of the rich and
developed countries in the world
well it's not really that simple
[Music]
could mauritius end up like the dodo
in addition to its beaches and years of
discrete banking mauritius is also known
for being the island of the dodo a small
flightless bird endemic to this place
which became extinct
in the 17th century well many analysts
are now wondering
whether mauritius apparent miracle or
economic takeoff is not in danger of
ending
just as badly as you can imagine in a
country so dependent on tourism and
international investments the
coronavirus crisis is hitting this small
republic
very hard to give you an idea gdp is
facing an historic fall but the public
deficit has soared above 20
and the registration of new offshore
companies has plummeted but hold on one
moment because although the effects of
the coronavirus are most likely to be
temporary in this case what is most
worrying
about this island nation is the
transformation it is undergoing and its
economic model
you see since 2018 mauritius has been
making significant changes in its tax
and banking system changes that
eliminate certain advantages with the
aim of ceasing to be considered by
international bodies as a
non-cooperative tax jurisdiction the
country is also building a tax model
more similar to that of developed
countries with a general increase in all
tax rates however taxes will
still be much lower than in most
developed countries meanwhile they have
also continued to implement the changes
to favor the attraction of capital for
example
since 2018 they've reduced the minimum
capital requirements of one hundred
thousand dollars to open a company to
just half that
in other words mauritius faces the
challenge of ceasing to be strictly what
we know as a tax haven governed by total
anonymity to becoming a model country
with low taxes and few regulations but
fully comparable to the international
reality
a model in which for example the state
will have more clout than it has had in
recent decades but will continue to
attract both investment
and capital we are a small island that
is limited in many ways we don't have
any natural resources
we need to have an edge over others to
be attractive so i think the advantage
in taxation
is important provind jugnoth prime
minister of mauritius
let's say that the idea for the local
elite is for mauritius to evolve from
being essentially a financial and
tourist center to becoming an important
commercial enclave for transactions with
sub-saharan africa something like a
singapore of africa
the gateway to the most uncharted
continent for capital investment
and trade a bridge between africa and
asia the question is will its low
taxes and legal certainty be enough to
maintain its good economic performance
will mauritius continue to be an example
of stability and development for the
rest of the continent or
will it ceasing to be a tax haven signal
the decline of its unblemished economic
trajectory
so my friends this is the story of one
of the most unknown african lions but at
the same time
one of the most successful a country
that not only proves that escaping
poverty is possible
even in africa but one that also became
a role model for other countries
on the continent a model that in some
way other countries like the ivory coast
are starting to imitate in their
attempts to become the next african
lions but we will talk about all this in
a future video here on visualpolitik you
know what i'm going to say now so don't
forget to subscribe to the channel to
keep up with all of our other news and
of course if you found this video
interesting don't forget to hit the like
button take it easy guys and
as always i'll see you next time if you
want to learn more about politics and
world affairs and hear some more of my
lovely voice
come check out the reconsider podcast
where we don't do the thinking for you
find reconsider at
www.reconsidermedia.com or on apple or
google play or your favorite podcatcher